[Música]
bienvenidos en este programa cultural
muy especial en 224 sobre la salsa y los
amantes de la salsa y en las llamas de
la capital mundial de este arte cálido
[Música]
durante cuatro días el festival mundial
de la salsa de cali celebró su regreso
en presidencial con una decimosexta
edición marcada por talleres un sueño en
mibu charlas conferencias muchos
espectaculares gratuitos la directora
del festival ariana olarte los compartió
su felicidad de volver a un evento
físico y dos con tumbos jacques y en
cali las alzas de vivir de una manera
tan única y fuerte
[Música]
después de una ilusión virtual
como usted se siente bueno como
directora pero también como caleñas de
ver los artistas aquí de nuevo en el
escenario y el público aquí de nuevo
bueno yo feliz de vernos acá pero no ha
sido fácil porque ellos más que ser un
festival por hacerlo el análisis que yo
hago antes de ejecutar el recurso
público es decir para que lo hago no
porque lo hago para que yo lo hago para
que lo hago también no sólo por lo
económico es por una salud mental
porque nosotros somos de un clima cálido
y el caleño le gusta estar afuera nos no
le gusta encontrarse dialogar la calle
tocar una campana agüero una moda
nosotros somos así somos amables me
encanta que vengan turistas
queremos que nuestra ciudad los abrazos
les proteja y los cuidemos y nosotros y
eso es el festival el responde a lo que
somos por eso es que nuestro adn
haciendo nosotros y porque un festival
un mundial además de salsa acá en
calidad y no en cuba o en puerto rico
tenemos investigadores en este momento
juan
de españa de brasil que están aquí en
festival y el dicen que esto es muy loco
porque nuestra gastronomía es un grupo
de popular 30
la ropa ellos como viste en la pinta la
pinta el baile de los ves con sombrero
tiene una identidad es la música nuestra
salsa está permeada por el pacífico
porque a hora y media tenemos el mar
pacífico
entonces nuestra sonoridad y nuestra
cadencia y nuestra chicanería en nuestra
coquetería también responde a esa mezcla
de culturas eso hace que nosotros como
capital mundial que mucho la llama la
diferencia con unos otros países es que
el ecosistema está está identificado
caracterizado y por eso
portal eterna
qué pasó
[Música]
en cali y las alzadas se baila s
disfrutar todo el año hay eventos
especiales comunes mundial como la feria
o como el petronio que es el festival de
la música del pacífico pero también hay
fiestas con familiares y con amigos y
hay clubes como el de pero comer esas
salsotecas forman parte de la vida de
los caleños y por eso los meses de
confinamiento fueron aún más duros acá
el zaperoco incluso pensó que tenía que
cerrar sus puertas para siempre por
culpa de la crisis generada por la
pandemia de kobe 19 al final gracias al
apoyo de sus clientes el bar volvió a
acoger a todos los fans de la salsa
[Música]
en cuenta pero tenemos 28 años la
existencia
pues es un espacio que se ha ganado como
una esquina del corazón de los caleños y
también se ha vuelto pues un referente
en el cual vienen las personas
visitantes a vivir esto que la cultura
demuestra que la adoptamos en la cultura
de la salsa
qué pasa la gente que se quedó toda la
pandemia en la casa ahora viene como una
avalancha a buscar dónde a bailar donde
divertirse dónde escuchar salsa donde
compartir con nosotros de nosotros del
cariño entonces la gente está saliendo
desbocadamente a bailar
[Música]
que nacimos en caliente importante este
tipo de signo que se conserven y que
podamos estar
como en familia todos aquí reunidos
[Música]
la ciudad de cali tiene una relación muy
estrecha con la salsa casi difusión no
se notaba en la música que se puede
escuchar desde las ventanas abiertas de
los coches hasta en monumentos de
homenaje como esta estatua de la leyenda
piper pimienta sin embargo la salsa no
sería nada sin los melómanos sin los
profesores de baile y sin los
coleccionistas o sea todos los
apasionados para quien esta cultura es
algo cotidiano estas historias son las
de tres hombres que mantienen viva la
salsa en cali si no todos los caleños se
arriesgan a subir a siloé un barrio
popular y estigmatizado por su historial
de violencia pero un melómano intenta
cambiar esa imagen promoviendo
precisamente así encuentros entre
salseros
nos llena de mucha alegría los melómanos
y coleccionistas de que haya un espacio
acá en siloé donde se refleje la
historia de grupo niche y el maestro
jairo varela que era uno de los grandes
compositores en la historia de la música
de colombia y la música del mundo no
sí lo es la salsa se apodera de las
paredes pero sobre todo del mirador aquí
se citan coleccionistas artistas y
amantes de la salsa para disfrutar de la
música y del paisaje objetivo mostrar
que el arte y la cultura tienen un lugar
incluso en territorios abandonados por
el estado tengo mi sonido lo que yo
tengo en mí o lo que yo tengo no lo he
gestionado y lo pongo en el espacio
porque soy nacido y criado aquí en donde
estoy
vengo en situaciones difíciles de
pandillas y yo puedo salir adelante como
la nueva generación en una poder que nos
fracasen de 15 y 10 años sino que vean
en la cultura en el deporte y en la
salsa porque la salsa es patrimonio de
cali de cali la capital mundial de la
salsa y si lo aportan desde salsa han
mirado si lo están en esa cultura hacia
la comuna 20 santiago de cali porque no
a nivel del mundo no
[Música]
i
quinto
bajando hacia la comuna 12 en el corazón
de calling otro miguel busca ayudar a la
comunidad a través de los ritmos de la
salsa ofreciendo un espacio seguro de
esparcimiento este bailarín y coreógrafo
profesional deja en claro que su lucha
no es personal sino más bien colectiva
en años anteriores he tenido la
oportunidad de que me van a hecho
propuestas para irme para europa para
eeuu para la verdad no pues porque para
mí esto representa muchísimas cosas sino
entender son son muchísimo valor valores
agregados que si entro a explicar pero
se nos hace corta esta entrevista pero
representa mucho y no una sola palabra
pasión
sabemos que lo que con lo poco que es
quien me dio aporta aquí miguel no puede
sostener esta academia pero él lo hace
porque a él le gusta y le gusta traer
los jóvenes para apoyar
apoyarlos como tratar de sacarlos de la
calle en nuestra academia un mes de
clases cuesta 40 mil pesos colombianos
es decir unos 10 dólares estadounidenses
la recaudación es insuficiente para
sostener su modesta sala de baile por
eso siguen la financia enseñando en
otras academias pues quiero
transmitirles antes que nada pues que
esto es una disciplina que tiene que
esto les tiene que fluir desde la sangre
eso les tiene que gustar antes que nada
porque si no les gusta no van a
encontrar ni el sabor ni los demás
componentes para poderlo expresar estoy
digamos que tú empiezas ya y primero que
les guste y ya en ese orden de ideas muy
bien en la disciplina viene la
constancia del trabajo fuerte y si no
hay trabajo fuerte no hay resultados
como dicen en brasil sin orden no hay
progreso
para finalizar nuestro recorrido
llegamos al barrio donde nació esta
expresión artística como los de guayacán
el que había en el barrio obrero se
vuelve a romper todo estamos en cali el
barrio obrero de la ciudad de la alegría
y con toda detrás de una discreta puerta
se esconde el museo de la salsa durante
50 años el padre de carlos tomó
fotografías a los mejores artistas que
visitaron cali lo que era una colección
privada se convirtió en un lugar
emblemático para el género afro caribeño
y aquí está la memoria de esos artistas
que son tan importantes para los latinos
que que sabes que esto nos mueve el
apoel pueblo el olor a el olor a
personas a que somos cálidos que
existimos me parece que es muy bonito y
sentimos que tenemos que sacar pecho y
decir que está en cali está en vargas
así es como en pocos metros cuadrados
carneros y su familia rinden homenaje a
la salsa desde la loma al valle la salsa
se baila se siente y se mira a lo largo
de toda la calle la sucursal de la
ciudad
juego
[Música]
la salsa tiene en su adn la calle esta
cultura nació entre las manos y los pies
de personas de lugares populares al
igual que el barrio obrero en calles
entonces invitará a brasil para esta
edición número 16 del mundial de la
salsa que haya por su propio peso una
bailarina de samba y una pareja de salsa
caleña hicieron juntos una presentación
de estas dos expresiones populares ellos
nos compartieron sus sentimientos
después de este intercambio cultural
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
muy
caluroso
[Música]
y qué
género
[Música]
realmente no es como el estilo de baile
de la nacionalidad sino la pasión que
realmente nos une a todos los valores de
manera mundial entonces es muy chévere
demostrarle eso que nosotros sentimos y
transmitimos con el cuerpo al público
que estaba acá
[Música]
así termina es especial sobre las armas
que pueden ver este programa y muchos
más en france 24 disparos 24 puntos
muchas gracias
[Música]